Please welcome my friend, Joel McHale!
(audience cheering)
(indistinct)
Oh thank you, spare bedroom.
Thank you.
(laughing)
This is so nice of you.
Drew, you look amazing,
and you're dressed kind of like
post St. Patrick's day
chic.
That's exactly right.
Happy post St. Patrick's day.
Are you Irish?
Oh yeah.
You know, it's been a minute since we've seen each other,
and I was giggling with delight
at you and your teenage boys.
And
I just was so excited
that your boys,
like, did they get the funny gene?
I heard they're sarcastic, Edward and Isaac.
Oh yeah.
When they were born,
when the first one was born, now he's 16.
My dad, who I gave endless amounts of crap to,
he was just like,
"You
are in for it."
And he wasn't joking so like,
they'll watch like, "Community".
Thank you!
They'll watch "Community" and be like,
hey dad, we really liked that episode
except for your acting, it was terrible.
And I'll be like, okay, great.
And then they'll, you know, I'll just be like...
"Hey guys, dinner's ready!"
And then my kids will go, "Oh okay dad."
(audience laughing)
What did I do?
Or, you might experience this.
They'll be in their bedroom, like playing a video game
or on a chat call, or I don't know what they're doing,
but I'll come in and they'll just go, "What?"
And I'll be like...
what do you mean what?
This is my house I paid for it.
Olive always pulls that. "This is my house".
I'm like, I don't think so, because I don't remember
seeing your name on the last payment.
She's eight, almost nine going on like 15.
It's insane.
I have full blown teenage problems with her.
I have, like my 16 year old would be like...
"Hey dad, when do you think you'll be relevant again?"
(laughing)
Oh my god!
What's happening?
Joel, Olive was mad at me the other night.
And her sister was like, "No, but our mom is like, great."
And she goes, "She's just some entertainer."
(audience chuckling)
Oh, yeah.
That's when you should go into the "Gladiator" speech,
and be like, am I here?
Are you entertained?
That is...
Yeah I will sometimes just turn off the lights
and go, oh look who pays for that, me!
And then I'll click it back on again.
And I'll be like, you're warned.
You've been warned.
It's just that when they start driving cars,
I don't know what's gonna happen.
I fear for the city of Los Angeles.
I know.
I can't believe anyone let me have a driver's license at 16.
I'm sad to say it got taken away from me right away.
Like, I didn't last a year before I got that thing revoked.
(laughing)
What did you do?
Several moving violations
like within the first year.
Yeah!
And they just swiped it away
and it was gone for like a year or two.
And I went from feeling so cool in my Jeep,
to right back to, can I get a ride?
That, yeah, I, so my brothers,
one is 21 months younger
and the other one is 26 months older.
So we were dri-
It was like, you know, 15 with a permit, 17 driving, and 19.
We totaled four cars,
two and a half years.
And my dad was like, "I'm going to have a tick."
"I'm going to have a tremor because of you guys."
Yeah.
And we were pushing cars off the side
of the road that we accidentally ran into stuff.
And I don't know how we survived.
That's I think that's the point of ki-
I was told that like...
Oh, you have a boy?
Your job is to keep them alive until they leave the house
because they will find a way to just jump stuff
and jump off railings.
So yeah, I have a tick now.
Well, I love that, you know,
you and your wife have been together
for 25 years, is that right?
We will be married 25 years in July.
And so 27 years together.
And I don't know why, Drew.
But she has agreed to be with me for all these years.
She has tolerated so much.
She does the classic like...
"Yes, I have two boys and an infant,
and the infant's name is Joel."
So I'm very, very lucky and yeah,
I hope we can be together for another 27.
Gosh, I just love that you guys
have been together 27 years
and want to be together another 27.
Any tips for a good marriage?
Well, she laughs at about 5% of my jokes.
Constant like me trying to get her to laugh.
So if I tell her a joke, she'll go,
"Oh yeah, 'A' material there, Joel".
(audience laughing)
What the?
So you're getting it
from all ends.
And I'll be like, "I'm a professional!"
I would say the best advice I ever got for a
happy marriage
is "Happy wife, happy life."
And if she's happy, I'm happy.
Everyone's happy.
Listen, humor doesn't hurt.
And you have a new movie
which, ironically, is called "Happily"
about a married couple,
but it's so apparently crazy and intense and
delectable.
We couldn't show a clip.
What is up with that?
Yeah. This movie is about a couple that
has been married for 14 years, and they are very amorous.
They still are as frisky as they were when
they got married, and all their friends hate them for it.
So, and then it gets pretty crazy.
So it's like an episode of "The Twilight Zone"
with just a lot of, a lot of sex.
I'm really glad that you brought it with this movie,
and I'm so excited
and it just seems so delicious and so fun.
And listen, we could all use a little, you know,
"inspo" to keep it frisky and fun.
So I just love the tone of this movie
that you're putting out there
I think it's gonna
Thank you.
be very well embraced.
And I do feel like if someone said,
"You can watch this movie about a couple
having problems, or you can watch this couple
like, get it on and have a blast
with a fun twist at the end,"
there's no question which one I'm picking.
I'm picking the good couple every single time.
That was a lot of what Victor wanted
with "Santa Clarita Diet".
He said, "I don't want to watch this couple fight.
I'm not interested in that."
People have to do that.
You know, in life, let's look at a couple
that finds their way out of things and is successful.
And there's a lightness there.
I will say on the "Santa Clarita Diet" set
and on "Blended"
the crew adored you, which is a very good sign.
Just so you know, folks,
that when the crew doesn't like an actor, you can feel it.
And it's not a fun place.
And when they do like an actor, it's a playground.
So that is...
I always go like, at the end of, people,
they do work, they do stuff.
But at the end of the day, at the end of your life,
you're like you made a bunch of people happy
for a lot of hours of their life.
Like (imitates farting) congratulations, Drew Barrymore.
Thank you, Joel McHale
See what I did?
for saying that.
You did, and I'm going to turn it right back on you,
and say all the stuff you've put out into the world
has been fun and wonderful.
(upbeat music)